Walaupun komputer kuantum tak sesuai untuk menyelesaikan
semua masalah, ada beberapa kelas masalah
dan potensi kes penggunaan di mana kita jangka
pengkomputeran kuantum akan memberi impak.
Ia termasuk simulasi seperti
pemodelan proses dan sistem yang berlaku dalam
alam semula jadi, carian dan pengoptimuman
yang melibatkan pencarian penyelesaian terbaik atau
optimum dalam situasi yang ada
banyak jawapan yang mungkin, dan matematik
serta pemprosesan data berstruktur kompleks
termasuk aplikasi untuk pembelajaran mesin.
Algoritma kuantum mengambil pendekatan baru untuk
masalah-masalah seperti ini, dengan memanfaatkan
ciri-ciri unik fizik kuantum seperti
superposisi, gangguan, dan entanglement.
Komputer biasa tersangkut
meneroka kawasan tertentu dalam ruang pengiraan
jadi mereka tak dapat cari corak-corak ini.
Komputer kuantum dilengkapi dengan
keupayaan tambahan atau prestasi yang lebih tinggi
untuk sesetengah masalah berkat sifat kuantum mereka.
Untuk betul-betul faham potensi komputer kuantum
ia memerlukan pemahaman mendalam tentang teori kerumitan pengiraan,
satu cabang sains komputer yang berpusat pada
pengukuran dan perbandingan usaha pengiraan yang
diperlukan untuk menyelesaikan pelbagai jenis masalah.
Ini memberi kerangka yang berguna
untuk menerangkan pelbagai peningkatan kelajuan
dan kelas masalah yang dijumpai dalam
pengkomputeran.